militants who say they targeted critical
Saudi Arabian oil facilities in a drone
strike are threatening more attacks the
Trump administration blames Iran for the
strike that damaged one of the Saudis
most important oil export sites 'iron
calls that claim meaningless the attack
cut the world's oil supply by about five
percent in the market price of crude oil
jumped nearly 20 percent before falling
back
we Jiang is at the white house we should
good morning how is President Trump
responding good morning Tony President
Trump says the US has reason to believe
they know exactly who is behind the
attacks and is quote locked and loaded
but he also says that he's waiting to
hear who the Saudis blame before
deciding how to move forward his top
diplomat is using much stronger language
pointing the finger directly at Iran
vice president Mike Pence defense
secretary mark Esper and Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo left the White House
Sunday evening as tension between the
u.s. and Iran barrels toward a boiling
point satellite images show thick black
smoke billowing from the Aramco oil
facility in ab geek one of the saudi oil
plants attacked an apparent drone
strikes CBS News has learned there were
19 points of impact damaging 17
structures at the site saudi officials
indicated cruise missiles were used in
Yemen's Houthi rebels who are fighting a
civil war against the Saudi backed
government took responsibility for the
attack but Pompeo declared there is no
proof to support the claim and swiftly
blamed Iran on Saturday he tweeted Iran
has now launched an unprecedented attack
on the world's energy supply Iran
dismissed Pompeius accusations as
fruitless and blind its foreign minister
tweeted having failed at max pressure
secretary Pompeo 'he's turning to max
deceit before the attack President Trump
said he might meet with his Iranian
counterpart at the United Nations
General Assembly next week Pompeyo went
a step further clear he's prepared to
meet with no preconditions
yesterday President Trump contradicted
that on Twitter writing the fake news as
saying that I am willing to meet with
Iran no conditions that is an incorrect
statement as usual Republican
congresswoman Liz Cheney says the US
should deny visas to Iranian delegates
planning to attend the UN gathering the
White House has not indicated if
President Trump plans to do that but he
would not be the first Yale President
Obama and Reagan have denied visas to
Iranian diplomats we should thank you
very much